cinnamon toast crunch the cinnamon toast
crunch is good best cereal i mean you're
number one i mean you're eating cubes of
sugar but it's you can't beat it give me
give me your top five sugar cereals
right i like cinnamon toast crunch i
like pops
damn what pops just those yellow core
pops are underrated i like lucky charms
weird ones all right and i like charms
oh yeah overrated one too i'm eating
fruit i mean marshmallows i know
just stop just give me all marshmallows
what's with that
that's how life works you gotta have a
little struggle with your reward you're
turning this into a philosophical
conversation right yeah
you gotta have a little uh little rain
then some sunshine that's you can't just
go all sunshine blizzard baby yeah a
marshmallow blizzard
all right we got three what else by the
way ted alexandro's joke how all the the
uh horrible uh what do you call those
like traumatic what are those called god
damn it when like a hurricane or oh my
hurricane mudslides
natural disaster he's like the menu at
tgi friday's unleashing its wrath on the
universe that's a great joke
great joke they're all drinks hurricane
mudslide and uh the other one you said
love ted um
so uh all right yeah okay we got three
what else uh i'm blanking on a lot of
them but i'll throw froot loops in there
love fruitless love a friend it's a
classic classic and i'm holding grams
ah
crackling oat bran oh that's that's my
number one [ __ ] what that's grandpa
food it's good grandpa food oat oat
graham what jaclyn uh oat bran mad am i
crazy you guys not doing this anything
with bran i'm out oh it's sugary though
it's really good okay okay
crackling oat brand's my [ __ ] that's a
game changer right there i've never even
heard of crackling oat bran you better
we're having on one of these episodes
that sounds like soul food crack when i
was growing up there was cracklings what
you're supposed to do with the crackling
brand is you take the spoon you light a
flame underneath it
but uh no i like that
i think life is underrated if we're
going life is okay like okay it's not in
the top 5 but i want to give you an
honorable mention all right i'll give it
a mention i don't like the name life i
think it's too dark life sucks
you should try the other cereal hospice
that's terrible
yeah all right life support
what else oh cap'n crunch is killer it
is good i'll tell you it does [ __ ] up
the top of your mouth it does get a
little chunky up there but captain
crunch peanut butter
and we're really going full
black tar yeah
reese's pieces came out with a cereal
and it was bananas peanut butter puffs
peanut butter puffs best cereal on the
planet that's my number one objective
damn all right so that i'm thinking what
else frosted mini wheats how do you feel
i love frosting many weeds i like how
they get a little gooey at the end i do
enjoy
i'm 100 with you i just saw a guy
there's a guy in tick tock i forgot his
name he's a black guy with an amazing
voice and he just ranks food john legend
[Laughter]
um he ranks food and he's so they're
funny as hell and he does cereal and he
shits on
uh frosted mini wheats and i i got to go
against him on that one i love oh really
if you know that guy's name put it in
the comments because he's so funny he's
on tick tock he's got a huge following
he just does he just ranks food oh okay
oh you know what ain't bad either there
they are there's the reese's is uh
smacks
also
first of all they're like now we're
talking drugs here well i know they look
like little [ __ ] they look like little
vaginas but they're also i threw up one
against my nose
i like to run against my dick
but yeah they look like tiny clams and
uh
they taste pretty good but yeah that guy
looks like a dealer though look at him
does he's got that frog he's just like
he's like all right quick pay me quick
sugar smell maybe quick
you know we forgot i'm sure we'll get
shifter for getting uh count chocolates
pretty oh yeah that's old school boy
good good call me anything else we
forgot i don't i didn't like cooking
honey bunches of oats is great but
that's not like a sugariest thing but
it's got sugar in it but they they play
the whole we're a health food but it's
not it's the same as life
life is better than that
in terms of like i think it's healthier
but no you know what they do they it's
like the kind bar [ __ ] where it's like
covered in caramel oh yeah they're like
this is a hell i'm like it's a [ __ ]
snickers dude it's a snickers with a
cool wrapper that's it and it's called
kind
wait a minute what is that one that's
got a funny name is it honey bunches of
votes there's one where it's got a funny
name and they say it in the commercial
and everybody goes ah
it's like a joke
oh
god damn it it's a funny name cereal how
do you feel on weight on wheaties
wheaties stinks it's all right it's just
cardboard with milk
i guess cardboard's okay i don't mind it
i remember when getting on a wheaties
box was a big deal if you're an athlete
like he got a wheaties box of course of
course bruce jenner but i don't think if
you put
uh fruit and sugar in a cereal it's
already out
i don't like when people put the like
like honey nut cheerios is good on its
own yeah but you gotta berate
that's your sugar and cardboard yeah
yeah cardboard i need sugar on cardboard
kick sucks too [ __ ] you kicks kicks
rocks
kicks yeah ki x too they thought they'd
be really hyped yeah yeah it was okay it
wasn't horrible but it was you know you
were never excited right cheerio is a
solid ah i mean you got to put oh you
got to put a strawberry in it or it's
boring that's that to me that means you
suck
you know what's interesting it's like
apple jacks apple jacks was something a
little too happily for me
there was one with a funny name that's
gonna kill me
all right honeycomb no no
no sucked it's weird when uh it's you
know what's fun about the cereals though
is like you see they try to do the
different brands and stuff yeah but the
it's like cocktails the classics survive
yes you know like negroni manhattan
right but then they french toast crunch
who [ __ ] with that i tried it i had a i
had a bender on that i'm not gonna lie
to you it's good it's pretty good i went
to vegas and it blacked out and had it
but
uh it's uh it's it's okay it's probably
the most innocent vegas blackout story
ever i woke up with milk all over me
empty bowl empty spoon
but yeah yeah it did hook her but yeah
it wasn't
oh tricks suck coco pebbles is solid
only could you get that chocolate milk
at the end yeah that chocolate milk was
a bonus for sure yeah tricks tricks
wasn't bad silly rabbit tricks are for
kids why i that was the worst worst
marketing of all time yeah what'd you
say the best milk was from the reese's
oh yeah a great meal you got great milk
butter milk
why did they ever make they made like
strawberry chocolate milk they made you
know obviously chocolate they made
vanilla where's the peanut butter
chocolate very right nesquik listen up
that's gold peanut butter milk
i just had a shake the other i'm a big
milkshake queef and i had a peanut
butter milkshake and it was dynamite is
that your go-to well i like chocolate
peanut butter mix but they don't always
have it sometimes you get a banana in
there it's kind of
peanut butter and banana is nice i get
that my smoothie yeah which is basically
a milkshake